[Music]
foreign
cooking with charcoal on small stoves
called Chico is commonplace in
sub-Saharan Africa for those on low or
unpredictable incomes charcoal is
readily available and easier to Source
than other fuels like gas
is
1500
50 Kenyan shillings is roughly half a US
dollar
cheap charcoal is a vital part of many
lives
because that's the source of energy
people use there's an entire industry
that's being born to cut down forests
make charcoal and sell it to people as
much as 47 billion dollars worth of
charcoal is sold across Africa every
year
and while many Ordinary People benefit
from this economy it's also having a
more negative impact
charcoal production is the leading
driver of deforestation in Africa and is
also blamed for shortening lives
This indoor air pollution actually kills
as many as 4 million people according to
the United Nations you also have to cut
down the trees from active forests to be
able to burn the wood for energy users
and that means that releases carbon
dioxide and because you're deforesting
there is carbon that's stored in the
soil in the forest which is also
released so it's bad for health it's bad
for the planet
one nairobi-based startup says it can
disrupt this huge Market by replacing
the charcoal with a cleaner burning
bioethanol that would also save African
forests
we look at the potential or for a
solution across 60 countries across
Africa South and Central America and
Asia that is where we see a lot of use
of firewood and charcoal and a lot of
deforestation
[Music]
cocoa Network sources its fuel from
sugar processing plants like this one in
Western Kenya
rather than chopping down trees to make
firewood or charcoal the sugar molasses
that's converted into ethanol is a waste
byproduct
cocoa distributes this cleaner burning
fuel to a network of so-called cocoa
points in densely populated areas in
Kenya
the machines like ATMs for cooking fuel
are placed in general convenience stores
their customers insert a smart canister
and using a pin code fill up as much as
they need
once the canister has been filled it's
plugged into a special two hob cooker
designed with safety in mind
one of the leading causes of fires
especially in informal settlements comes
from charcoal fires and kerosene stoves
but my little decoration
is
foreign
[Music]
foreign
so from cutting down air pollution
bioethanol is quite clean because it
burns without producing all this
particulate matter that is usually
breathed in by women mostly who are
doing the cooking and then it goes all
parts of the body even to the brain so
there is no doubt that cutting down on
air pollution by using these alternative
fuels is a good idea
for customers switching to a cleaner
fuel like Cocos bioethanol can make a
huge difference and not just to their
health
the system allows canisters to be filled
by as little as 30 Kenyan shillings
about 25 us cents so if money is tight
day to day a customer can buy just
enough for that one meal
the ethanol is cheaper than charcoal and
competes on price with kerosene which
the government subsidizes thank you
the system also appears to work well for
shopkeepers who host the Coco point 2.
[Music]
before then he sees like around 20 20
liquid twice a week like right now in a
day
Coco says one in four Nairobi households
are now cooking with their fuel
according to data from the United
Nations there's a reduction of over five
tons of greenhouse gas emissions per
household per year when changing from
charcoal to a bioethanol like cocoa
[Music]
when you're talking about 585 000
households and these are people who've
converted from using charcoal we've
provided them with a guaranteed fuel
purchase so you're guaranteed that you
will go to your cocoa point you will get
fuel no matter how much money you have
we're Within Reach
of course we have to be careful about
bioethanol and how it's sourced right
now it's being sourced from the waste
produced in sugar cream processing but
if the demand for this product grows we
need to be careful that we don't end up
using cropland for the solution because
there is not enough land to be able to
feed all the billions of people around
the world
Coco wants to Target countries all over
the world where populations rely on
charcoal or wood burning fuel
but to do so they say they need
financial support to keep their products
competitive as well as long-term
guarantees to maintain and attract
investment
we want fiscal incentives in in the form
of tax exemptions on all our hardware
and all our fuel and more importantly we
need carbon credits to remain the
property of cocoa networks that is
important because we use the carbon
credits to subsidize both the cooker and
the bioethanol and that is why we tell
the government give us the leeway give
us the exemption so that we are able to
invest a lot faster get to a lot of this
household sooner rather than later
because we are seeing the impact of
climate change we are seeing what we're
experiencing right now so the sooner
they give us exemptions the sooner we're
able to make the investment the sooner
kenans can start experiencing their
benefits
next year they're hoping to start
operations in Rwanda where the
governments agree to waive taxes and
import duties a model Coco says is
essential to getting cleaner fuel into
more households to level the playing
field with charcoal which is entirely
untaxed
any kind of startup coming out with a
new technology has to compete with
existing Solutions in the market and as
a new technology it's not always going
to be able to be as cheap as what's
available on the market so sometimes it
helps if governments can step in in this
case many governments have stepped in to
cut taxes on fuel and that goes a long
way in making the product competitive in
the market but there's another challenge
for startups which is that they need to
be able to grow and so if there are ways
in which that can be overcome by
providing more skilled staff and
supportive financing than these kinds of
technologies that cut emissions but also
address other problems that are energy
access air pollution can go a long way
in helping develop a growing region
foreign
[Music]